Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Jagri Bayram. Ich bin als Assistenzarzt hier auf des Stationstätich.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Guten Abend, Herr Doktor. Ja, natürlich. Aber wie ist Ihr Name nochmal, bitte?
Jagri Bayram.
Was ist das? Was ist das für ein Name, Herr Doktor?
Das ist Türkchen Name.
Ein türkischer Name?
Ja.
Das klingt interessant. Ja, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Wie lange sind Sie schon in Deutschland, Herr Doktor?
Seit drei Jahren.
Oh, Sie sprechen aber gut Deutsch.
Danke, vielen Dank.
Man versteht Sie sehr gut.
Es gibt sehr viele Türken, die schon sehr lange hier in Deutschland leben,
aber leider nicht so gut Deutsch sprechen wie Sie.
Also, sehr schön.
Wo haben Sie die deutsche Sprache so gelernt?
Ja, danke.
Kurz zum unserem Gesprächablauf.
Als Erstes werde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Daten stellen.
Dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, mein Name ist Sieglinde Müller.
Normaler Müller.
Können Sie Ihren?
Mein Vornamen ist Sieglinde.
Können Sie bestabieren?
Ja, natürlich.
Siegfried Ida Emil, Gustav Ludwig Ida Nordpol, Dora Emil, Sieglinde.
Sieglinde, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
68? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 10. April 1966.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin etwas kleiner geworden.
Ich bin 1,69 m.
Und ich wiege ca. 65 kg.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Frau Müller?
Ach, Doktor, mein Haushalt hatte heute keine Zeit.
Deswegen komme ich heute zu Ihnen.
Ich habe seit gestern so Schmerzen im Bauch.
Auf der linken Seite tut es richtig weh.
Seit gestern.
Ja, und heute ist es etwas mehr geworden.
Wenn Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, sind Sie sehr duftig.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich, Herr Doktor.
Es gibt Phasen, da bekomme ich Krämpfe.
Auf der linken Seite des Strahls, so in den Unterbauch.
Und dann ist manchmal der Schmerz dumpf,
so dass ich auch nicht richtig sitzen kann.
Ich muss dann aufstehen, ich muss dann laufen.
Es ist sehr unangenehm.
Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich habe einen dicken Bauch.
Das drückt dann auch so ein bisschen auf den Bauch.
So richtig weg geht der Schmerz eigentlich nicht.
Das ist fast immer da.
Gibt es Ausdöser für diese Schmerzen?
Nein, das ist eigentlich immer da.
Egal, ob ich mich jetzt sitze, ob ich mich lege
oder ob ich laufe, der Schmerz ist immer da.
Wenn ich mich hinsetze, dann wird es manchmal etwas mehr sogar.
Oder wenn ich mich so ein bisschen beuge und bücke,
dann werden die Schmerzen etwas mehr.
Haben Sie einen Unfall erlebt?
Nein, im Fall hatte ich nicht.
Vorher haben Sie solche Beschwerden erlitten?
Ich hatte schon öfters mal Handwerksinfekt.
Aber das ist etwas anderes.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf eine Schmerz sind sie sehr leichte,
sie sehen sehr stark, die Schmerzen entspricht.
Gestern war das etwas weniger, bei 3-4.
Heute sind sie manchmal bis auf 7-8 angestiegen.
Jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Ich habe mir die Schmerzmedikamente genommen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen nicht mehr ausgehalten vor 3 Stunden.
Jetzt werden die Schmerzen ein bisschen weniger.
Was haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich hatte noch Norvalgien zu Hause.
Da hatte mir der Arzt das vor längerer Zeit mal aufgeschrieben.
Das habe ich mir jetzt genommen.
Haben Sie sonst weitere Beschwerden?
Ich habe noch ein paar andere Erkrankungen,
aber die sind im Moment nicht das Problem.
Sonst jetzt, ich war ich 3 Tage nicht auf Toilette.
Es tut mir auch schon weh, das muss ich sagen.
Da tue ich mir schwer.
Keine Stuhlgang.
Ist Ihnen übel oder müßtig?
Nein, ich habe keine Stuhlgang.
Ich habe eine leichte Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe sie bisher noch nicht gehabt.
Leiden Sie unter Sortbrennen oder Aufstoßen?
Jetzt nicht, aber Sortbrennen habe ich immer wieder mal.
Letzt vor ca. 1,5 Jahren.
Da habe ich meine Medikamente mitgegeben.
Ich habe die Medikamente immer wieder mitgegeben.
Ich habe die Medikamente mitgegeben.
Haben Sie Schuttefrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, das habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Framila?
Er ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber in den letzten 1-2 Tagen habe ich etwas weniger Appetit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich immer so wie immer.
Haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, ich habe seit einigen Jahren schon ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten mit dem Schlaf.
Das stimmt.
Ich werde öfters mal mehrfach in der Nacht wach.
Und dann kann ich nicht mehr einschlafen.
Warum wachen Sie in der Nacht?
Warum ich aufwache?
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann da nicht mehr schlafen.
Okay.
Natürlich gibt es einen bestimmten Grund.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen in der linken Seite.
Außerdem fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein.
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches Schmerzen?
Ich habe Unterbauchschmerzen.
Nicht Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ich habe falsch geschrieben.
Gibt es in Ihrer kranken Geschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Da habe ich einige Sachen, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe vor 5 Jahren mal einen Herzinfarkt.
Und habe einen Stand bekommen.
Dann habe ich Diabetes seit 10 Jahren ungefähr.
Aber das ist glücklicherweise gut eingestellt.
Ich habe eine Oberbauchschinkelfraktur.
Auf der rechten Seite war ich vor 2 Jahren gestürzt.
Vor 2 Jahren?
Ja.
Wie wurde sie gehandelt?
Ich musste operiert werden.
Ich habe da ein Metallteil drin.
Ich habe eine Metallteil.
Wenn das Wetter manchmal kalt wird,
dann bekomme ich Schmerzen.
Ist die Operation komplikationslos verlassen?
Ja, bei der Operation gab es keine Probleme.
Das war ganz gut.
Seit 2 Jahren habe ich so chronische Schmerzen im Rücken.
Im ländenwerbelbereich.
Ich habe auch eine Schmerz.
Das ist ein bisschen ein werbelbereich.
Mein Arzt meinte, das ist von der Arthrose.
Ein bisschen ein leichter Bandschein.
Ich nehme immer wieder Schmerzmedikamente.
Ich mache krankendemastisch.
Außer Oberbauchschinkelfraktur,
wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind glaube ich.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Meine Mutter sagte,
man hat mir die Mandel als Kind schon entfernt.
Frau Müller, Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie leiden unter Obstipation.
Seit 3 Tagen.
Wie war Ihre letzte Stuhl?
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Wie ist die Farbe?
Bisher habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme gehabt.
Ich habe immer wieder mal ein bisschen verstopft.
Aber wir waren dann auch wieder von alleine weg.
Der Stuhlgang war bisher immer in Ordnung.
Der Urin auch.
Da gab es bisher keine Probleme.
Wie war die Farbe und Konsistenz Ihres Stuhls?
Normalerweise.
Frau Müller, welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Regelmäßig oder gelegentlich ein?
Ich muss jetzt in meine Liste mal schauen.
Ich schulde gerade, meine Medikamente ist daraus.
Ja.
Ich habe A.100.
Das nehme ich einmal.
Und dann nehme ich Ramipril.
5 Milligramm.
Eine morgens eine Abend.
Dann habe ich hier Meto Prololl.
47,5.
Eine morgens.
Und hier habe ich Ato Vastatin.
20 Milligramm.
Am Abend eine.
Ich glaube, das ist gegen das Cholesterie.
Dann habe ich Jardians.
Das ist gegen den Diabetes.
Ich nehme eine Tablette.
Und mit Formin 850 Milligramm.
Eine morgens.
Eine Abend.
Und mein Bedarf nehme ich Paracetamol oder Ibuprofen.
Das passt.
Das ist für mich ein sehr guter Bedarf.
Ich habe eine Tablette.
Ich habe eine Paracetamol oder Ibuprofen.
Wie ist die Wichtag?
Die Dosis, meine ich.
47,5.
47.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe allergien einige Medikamente.
Das stimmt.
Da muss ich noch mal in meine Liste gucken.
Hier steht Dicklack.
Das ist ein Schmerzmedikament.
Da habe ich eine Allergie.
Und gegen...
Bitte?
Wie äußert sich die allergische Reaktion?
Da habe ich einen Ausschlag.
Und da ist noch eine Antibiotikum.
Das nennt sich Amoxiclav.
Wie äußert diese Allergie?
Ähnlich wie bei Dicklack aus.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Ich habe eine leichte Laktose.
Ich merke, wenn ich so Joghurtprodukte esse,
dass ich Blähungen bekomme.
Manchmal auch Durchfall.
Aber ansonsten ist mir nichts bekannt.
Frau Müller, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Früher? Haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, ich habe eigentlich nie geraucht.
Mein Mann hat mal Graubau.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr seltener, so fast gar nicht.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Oder haben Sie Drogen ausprobiert?
Das habe ich als junge Frau mal gemacht.
Aber ich habe keine Drogen.
Okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch Frau Müller?
Nein, die sind schon längst gestorben.
Darf ich fragen, woran Ihre Eltern gestorben sind?
Mein Vater ist schon im Krieg gestorben.
Dann habe ich gar nicht mehr gesehen.
Und meine Mutter starb an einem Schlaganfang.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwesterin.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, leider nicht. Sie hat vor drei Jahren ein Krebsdiagnose bekommen.
Brustkrebs.
Sie musste operiert werden.
Sie hatte Chemotherapie.
Jetzt geht sie ganz gut.
Aber das hat sie psychisch ziemlich kaputt gemacht.
Ich bin verheiratet. Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Frau Müller?
Ich bin Schneiderin.
Ich war Schneiderin.
Ich bin schon seit fünf Jahren in Rente.
Ich habe meine ganzen Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie mich oder verankert?
Ich möchte wissen, ob das gefährlich ist.
Das wird immer schlimmer mit den Schmerzen.
Das macht mir Angst.
Was glauben Sie, was das ist?
Wir als Erster haben immer drei Schritte,
um richtige Diagnose stellen zu können.
Anharmesische Schere, Körperich, Untersuchung
und Apparativdiagnostik.
Jetzt würde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann würde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Gegebenenfalls malche bildgebende Untersuchungen
veranlassen.
Dann gebe ich Ihnen über die weitere Schritte Bescheid.
Aber nach den bisherigen Angaben
gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf
vielleicht Ausschütteupunkt.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ein Verdacht.
Es braucht noch weitere Untersuchungen.
Was ist eine Ausschütteupunkt?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Es könnte sein, in Ihrem Diktar
eine Ausschütteupunkt, eine Ausbuchung entsteht.
Diese Krankheit,
vielleicht eine Ausstülpung,
eine Ausstülpung, eine Ausbuchung entsteht.
Diese Krankheit,
vielleicht solche Beschwerden verursachen.
Ach so, die Ausstülpung.
Nur die Ausstülpung.
Wie stellt man das fest?
Machen Sie einen Ultraschall?
Ja, als erstes, wir brauchen eine normale Grundgänge.
Aber um die Diagnose so zu sichern,
brauchen wir eine Koloskopie.
Das heißt eine Spiegelung.
Das wird aber schwierig.
Ich weiß seit 3 Tagen nicht auf Toilette.
Wie macht man das?
Vor der Spiegelung,
wir müssen ein Abwehrmittel.
Abwehrmittel.
Dann
eine Ausstülpung.
Dann führen wir diese Untersuchung durch.
Muss das wirklich sein?
Ich will das eigentlich gar nicht.
Da gibt es keine andere Möglichkeit,
um da festzustellen, was da ist.
Ja, könnte eine Tomografie.
Ja, das ist doch besser als der Spiel.
Können wir nicht zuerst eine Tomografie machen?
Es könnte sein.
Ich will das als erstes versuchen.
Die Untersuchung.
Das wäre mir lieber als die Darmspiegelung.
Vielen Dank.
Geben Sie mir etwas gegen die Schmerz?
Wenn Sie noch ein bisschen aushalten,
nach unserer Körperuntersuchung,
dann gebe ich Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel.
Bitte beeindruckt,
dass es nicht so schlimm ist.
Das verstehe ich.
Vielen Dank.
Haben die anderen Kollegen noch Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Welche Fragen hat der Herr Dr. Gessen zu fragen?
Ich habe keine gynaecologischen Fragen.
Was noch?
Sie haben nicht nach dem Mori gebacken.
Ich glaube, bezüglich Wasser lassen.
Genau, Wasser lassen.
Zwei wichtige Fragen.
Dann machen wir eine Urwärtsübergabe.
Ich brauche nur eine Minute.
Eine Minute noch.
Haben die anderen Kollegen noch Fragen?
Gibt es Probleme mit Ihrem Monatbudget?
In 65 Jahren?
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Die gibt es schon lange nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Geräut im Magendantrax?
Haben Sie Gas im Bauch?
Luftmein, Luft im Bauch.
Ich habe manchmal einen ganz dicken Bauch.
Ich habe oft sehr viel Luft im Bauch.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Bauch?
Nein, mit Mehlprodukten habe ich keine Probleme.
Es ist mehr mit Milchprodukten und Yogurt.
Sind Sie fertig?
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute eine Patientin vorstellen.
Erzählen Sie mal, schießen Sie mal los.
Was haben Sie für eine Patientin heute gehabt?
Ich habe keine Patientin.
Es geht um eine 68-Jährige Patientin.
Frau Siegel in der Müller.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns
wegen seit gestern bestehender,
kramfartiger, dünfer,
Unterbauchschmerzen in der linke Seite.
Okay.
Außerdem klackte die Patientin
den Bauchangfang-Anstieg.
Sie meinten von Blähung.
Blähung.
Blähung ist viel Luft im Bauch.
Aber ich dachte, das ist...
Okay.
Blähung bedeutet viel Luft.
Außerdem klackte die Patientin
über seit drei Tagen Obstipation.
Und so brennen.
Pyrosis, meine.
Dich im Merzen würden sich
verschlechten, wenn die Patientin
nach vorne, wenn die Patientin sich nach vorne beugeht.
Die Patientin hat sich nach vorne beugt.
Die Einnahme von Novalgin
habe etwas Linderung gebracht.
Die Patientin bewertete
die Intensität der Schmerzen
auf eine Schmerzkala
mit früher, mit
vier, aber heute mit
sieben, acht.
Okay.
Das ist das Schlimmerste.
Ja, die Schmerzen hätten sich
mit der Zeit verschlechtert.
Seit zwei Tagen habe die Patientin
in Appetitens.
Die weitere Vegetative an Amnesien
sei unerfällig.
An Vorerkrankungen leide die Patientin
seit fünf Jahren.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Die Patientin habe vor fünf Jahren
Myokartinfarkt erlitten
und ein, sei ein Stand
angelegt worden.
Implantiert oder eingesetzt worden.
Die Patientin
habe vor zwei Jahren
Obeschenkel fragt.
Erlitten, die operativ behandelt
wurde.
Seit zwei Jahren leide die Patientin
unter
Diskusprolaps.
Die Patientin sei in der Kindheit
Tonselektomie, Operation.
Nein.
Die Patientin habe sich in der Kindheit
eine Tonselektomie untersogen.
Sie haben gute Satz, Frau.
Sie hätten es anders gehalten.
Sie hätten sie in der Kindheit Tonselektomiert.
Tonselektomiert.
Beides mit.
Frau Müller, nehme
Acetyl Salicylsoyra 100 mg.
Einmal pro Tag.
2x pro Tag.
Metaprolol 47.5 mg.
Einmal pro Tag.
Atorvastatin 70 mg.
Einmal abends.
Cadians 10 mg.
Einmal pro Tag.
Metformin 850 mg.
Ich habe das mal beziehungsweise überprüfen, weil wir darf ein.
Die Patienten haben Allergie gegen die Klack, wahrscheinlich die Klophenack, die sich durch exanterme und puritus äußeren.
Okay. Die Klack ist die Klophenack, ja. Das ist richtig.
Und Amoxiclaw, Amoxicillin.
Amoxicillin und Klavulansäure, das ist dieses Kombination.
Das ist dieses Unacid, vielleicht kennen Sie das.
Okay. Die sich durch exanterme und puritus äußeren.
Frau Müller habe Lactosintoleranz, die Blähung und Diary, die so Blähung und Diary führt.
Ja, okay.
Frau Müller sei nicht Raucherin, trinke gelegenlich Alkohol, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Familienanamnästig fanden sich apoplechts bei der Mutter und ihre Vater bei Krieg gestorben.
Sie sind im Krieg gestorben.
Frau Müller habe eine Schwester, die vor drei Jahren wegen Brustkrebs operiert wurde.
Sie bekommen Chemotherapie.
Sie haben Chemotherapie bekommen.
Sie sei verheiratet, lebe mit ihrem Mann, habe ein Sohn, der gesund ist.
Sie sind berühmtete Schneiderin.
Sehr gut.
Aufgrund der Erhobene Anamnese gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf die Artikulitis.
Die Diagnostik ist an der Adnexitis, der Adnexialtorsion, die Harnweginfektion, die Harnwegstein oder Nefolithiasis.
Leiter, Leiterstein.
Im Betracht zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich überprüfe bei der Untersuchung Flankenklopfschmerz im Flankenbereich.
Bei der Palpassion überprüfe ich, ob Flötschmerzen abwärtsspänen und Spannung geht.
Ihr Internet ist jetzt weg.
Können Sie mich jetzt?
Ich höre Sie, das Bild steht, aber Sie reden durch weiter.
Darf ich meinen Bild schämen?
Ich höre Sie, das ist kein Problem.
Sie reden durch weiter.
Okay.
Außerdem erwarte ich bei der körperlichen Untersuchung linksseitige Druckschmerzen.
Die Laboruntersuchung könnte wichtige Hinweisen niffeln.
Im Labor sollten Blutbild-Gernungparameter, Entzündungparameter, Nierenwerten, Leberwerten und die Entzündungswerte überprüft werden.
Die Entzündungswerte machen auch nicht so?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Und vielleicht noch ein Tomogramm?
Ja, um die Diagnose zu sichern, sollte normalen Röntgen-Grafik abdominal Übersicht aufnehmen.
Kann man machen, natürlich ob eine freie Luft.
Und CT.
Ja.
CT-Untersuchung bei Computertomographik.
Was sehen Sie im Röntgen-Abdomen noch?
Welche Diagnose haben Sie vorhin vergessen?
Die Diagnose, was kann man noch sehen im Röntgen?
Was ist mit dem Bauch?
Die Kollege hat es vorhin aufgeschrieben.
Ilius.
Ilius?
Genau. Ilius.
Das ist eine Bar-Wack-Differenzialdiagnose, ne?
Ja, richtig.
Sehr gut.
Bei der CT-Untersuchung können wir Stimmen, wie kann man sagen,
abschwächte Stimmen, Bauchstimmen oder Darm-Geräusche.
Bei einem Ilius hat man keine Darm-Geräusche,
oder man hört abgeschwächte Darm-Geräusche.
Sehr gut.
Das war schon sehr gut, Herr Doktor.
Sie machen die Zusammenpassung, die Adonese,
eigentlich sehr ordentlich, die Aussprachen sind auch sehr gut.
Das muss man sagen, das ist schon viel besser geworden
als beim letzten Mal.
Differenzialdiagnose, genau.
Hätten Sie nach den Gynecologischen Sachen fragen müssen.
Dann nach den Hahnwegen, also Hahnleitern, Nieren,
Blase, Steine, hätte man fragen können.
Aber man als Differenzialdiagnose muss man natürlich auch
einen Darmpfverschluss, also an einem Ilius denken.
Die eigentliche gute Diagnose für eine Diverticulitis
ist nicht die Darbespiegelung, sondern ein CT.
CT.
Man würde als erstes das Kette relativ schnell.
Man muss den Darmen nicht abführen.
Man kann innerhalb von einer Stunde sagen,
ob da eine schwere Entzündung da ist,
ob eine Perforation vorliegt.
Das wäre das nächste.
Eine perforierte Diverticulitis.
Wie muss man das behandeln?
Ich habe einen Hauptfall.
Jawohl.
Ja, sollte die Patienten mindestens 2 Großelben in Tragenöse
Zugänge angelegt werden.
Also sie muss operiert werden.
Ganz kurz.
Wenn ihr die Zugänge, sie muss operiert werden.
Sehr gut.
Wann ist die Ihre Prüfung?
Morgen.
Wo?
München.
Das ist eine schöne Bayern.
Sie werden es bestehend.
Ich bin überzeugt, Sie machen es gut.
Dann erfahren Sie auch gleich morgen,
ob Sie bestanden haben?
Ja, ich fahre morgen nach München.
Und sagen Sie auch gleich, ob Sie bestehen oder nicht?
Ja, wir kommen gleichzeitig.
Dann sagen Sie uns morgen Bescheid.
Wir sind gespannt.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Vielen Glück.
Sehr gut.
Haben die anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
noch Fragen, Anregungen, Kritik, Bemerkungen?
Alle zufrieden.
Vielen Dank.
Ich danke auch.
Okay.